paul obscur écuries non seulement gérer
ça si on annonce avant j'étais tellement
désolée je suis n'importe où comme je
suis désolé pas grave
cette dernière fois qu'on vole d'accord
mais la dernière fois je déteste faire
ça et quand tu seras grand tu voleras
pas juré quand tu seras grand tu fera
exactement l inverse de ce qu on fait
ton père et moi tu me jure t shirts à
son chagrin comme vous j'ai soif mais il
est où le jus de fruits c'est qui ce mec
paumé ces personnes on s'en fout ben
alors est il est content ou pas c'est
cool c'est les vacances non installions
part en vacances lorsque tu peux être
cassante noël ça peut être aussi à paris
il ya des millions de chinois qui
viennent à paris visiter la tour eiffel
des grands magasins méthode quand même
plus compte de quoi tu t'en fout
complètement des chinois huawei